this
is dark talk i'm your host neil degrasse
tyson your personal
astrophysicist and we're going to go
slightly off format
today this is just going to feature my
conversation
with rayne wilson his fans know all
about him
and his portfolio and of course in fact
uh
he's in in a recent uh amazon prime
uh do i call it a mini series we'll find
out
uh and it's on a subject it depends on
if it has a season two
if it has so many season one it's a mini
series
rain wilson welcome to star talk dude
so this one i'm calling this my cosmic
crib because we're just
you and i are just chilling normally i
have like a co-host and experts and all
this
it's just you and i having a
conversation
reaching for our geek roots i love it
that's awesome let's do this
so um you're best known and do you hate
it when people say he's best known for
do you hate that when people do that no
no
come on i mean it's just true i'm best
just true
dwight schrute and uh that
in the office and and how many seasons
did that go that like it was
nine seasons that's crazy every time i
turn on there's the office
you know yeah yeah and so i just want
just congratulations for
being a fixture in that show and
especially
most recently um you have a show that
dropped a nine part
show that dropped uh and it's called
utopia
in which you play a virologist on that
so we'll
have to get to the bottom of that and
also
you've got a podcast of your own um
soul pancake will i ever be on soul
pancake
probably not probably not you wouldn't
make the cut i'm so sorry
um you're not legit enough no it's a
it's a it's a it's a podcast called
metaphysical milkshake
uh i did uh with reza aslan um
so soul pancake is your production and
soul pancake but it's so pancake is the
company that i co-founded
it's a it's a digital media company so
it's soul pancake presents
metaphysical milkshake they're very much
a part of it it's it's kind of in the
whole soul pancake vibe which is about
exploring life's big questions and
making uplifting content and bringing
people together and
and our podcast is is in sync with that
does that work today because no one
wants uplifting content
they thrive on conflict and tribalism
so so how's that working out well um
yes how is that working out you know
you're not following the facebook model
there is that there is a large
percentage of the population that is
looking for uplifting content
and unifying content and something that
contains hope
and uh and joy even um
and you know i just look at i mean you
saw the documentary the social dilemma
yes
yes yes yes um very interesting i mean
got right to the heart of the problems
yeah yeah yeah and i i mean i knew a lot
of the stuff that was in it before a lot
of people watch it and they're like well
i knew all that it's like
well yeah i knew it but it it wasn't put
together in
in the puzzle pieces weren't put
together in uh in a
in such a uh out coherent way and
and you see that so much of the division
going on in the world right now
is is this facebook model um if if they
can get you outraged they get you
clicking buttons more and they get more
ads
and they make more money so outrage and
division
fuels commerce so we're a digital media
company yes we would like people to
watch our videos
but we're trying to combat this by
bringing people together and using the
best aspects
of the web and of youtube and uh digital
content that is so noble i mean i'm
proud of you
and i hope it succeeds by greater than
all measures
because then others would then emulate
it and then it would maybe be this force
of attraction
uh away yeah from all that that
continues
to divide us and what's this in that
same production company
an idiot's guide to climate change oh
yes
you'll dig you dig this do i i keep
wanting to say dr
tyson it's dr neal to you
just neil just neal please i know but i
keep wanting to say dr tyson
why is that you command such respect i
never want to call anyone a doctor even
my own doctor i call it
it is fascinating many people call me
that and i never i don't
introduce myself that way when i give
public talks here's doctors
no i don't but so so i have to receive
it as a
as an as a an unsolicited honorific
yes and okay i'm warmed by it but still
it's it's not necessary
yeah um well okay neil all right neil
shut up here's here's what we're gonna
do um
so no you would dig this show uh an
idiot's guide to climate change here's
what we did
i i was i got involved with this
non-profit
called arctic base camp that basically
explores the science of
how climate change is affecting the
arctic and tries to really impart that
information to movers and shakers
because as you know
in the world of climate change what's
happening in the arctic is far more
extreme than
what's happening even in california i
mean yeah in fact when they say
we're warming the earth by one or two
degrees that that's the average
the arctic gets a much bigger hit from
that exactly almost double what we're
feeling in north america
right now so uh i got invited to take a
trip with them
to iceland and greenland and meet some
scientists that were working up there
and so we didn't really have a budget
for soul pancake it's just
it's a smallish company so but
on like a 60 000 budget we were able to
kind of pull together
i kind of documented myself on this trip
up to greenland
and we made it a six part series greta
turnburg is on the series
and the whole point of it was like
listen there's a lot of people that
believe in the science of climate change
of course as you always say you don't
believe in science science right right
but wait wait back up for a second how
did you can't just
fly to greenland so how how did this
happen so getting to greenland was
uh was a [ __ ] the scientists dr gail
whiteman who's the founder of arctic
base camp
and there were a bunch of other
scientists that were working up there
and she was like we were going to do a
bunch of events and she was like
rain i'm going up there to meet with
these scientists you should come along
and just see firsthand what's going on
we'll document it and you can make it
into this little series and then
as you know you can speak to science
much more when you've kind of like
lived it and gone through it so the
point of the show though neil was that
there's a lot of people that buy the
science there's a lot of people that
don't
buy the science and think it's kind of a
crazy liberal conspiracy
but there are some people in the middle
there are some young people in the
middle
that are kind of getting it from both
sides that you know maybe they've got a
crazy right-wing uncle that doesn't buy
yeah it's thanksgiving
it all happens at thanksgiving
thanksgiving dinner table
exactly and but maybe their friends at
school
are climate activists and you know or
something like that so
uh do fire drill fridays with jane fonda
or something so
they don't know what to think so i tried
to make it like i'm the doofus i'm the
idiot
um going who doesn't know anything about
climate change wants to learn something
that's going on this
this trek so it's fun i try and use
humor it's it's kind of
you know off-putting and um
it was it was a lot of fun we had uh
was on it and excellent did you glean
any tactics
any tools or the tools of communication
from that trip you know that's a great
question i didn't
i i don't know i don't know what to do
you know just
keep will i go what'll i do
i'm sorry i'm disappearing i thought you
said you were hopeful
dude
um i do think that we just need to keep
fighting the good fight
and trying and really work with young
people um
you know people over 40 or 50 that got
their minds made up you know they're
never going to change their minds so
yeah it does seem to be demographically
split that way that that's a fascinating
fact
and so that therefore the younger
demographic that they're tactically
different
if you're trying to get some of them off
the fence versus
you're right the old officer so try and
reach some of the young people and and
we can make a difference if we make
extreme changes right now throughout the
world we can
meet the goals of the paris agreement
it's going to be really really hard
but we can do it and we just have to
keep believing um that's it that's all i
got
okay well that's helpful and do you
think uh so
i'm just wondering if there should be
tourist jaunts to greenland to so they
can see
that that might help because i always
think what i think the flat earthers are
a conspiracy
just so that they're the first ones to
go into space
because that's where we're going to want
to send them so they can see the round
earth first hand so they get a free
just send them all get just do that you
know what so you don't even need to go
to space
you can just fly you can fly to europe
and you're up so high like the sun's
rising you see the curve of the earth
here's what you do you set them up into
space and say
you have to confess earth is round
otherwise we're not bringing you back
oh there you go perfect i would not
suggest
bringing people to greenland mostly
because the carbon footprint is so big
and i talk about that in the series but
just flying to greenland it's so much
gas and taxis and whatnot
i mean the only way to do it is if
you're gonna like i'm gonna plant a
freaking forest when i'm done flying to
greenland but
um just to make up for it and greta's
greta's quite the ambassador in that was
she on the same trip with you
or did coming to go in another time no
uh this guy who's on our board
callum grieves works with her and her
organization so he was able to kind of
patch her in
and we did it we shot remotely with her
she didn't go on the trip but
she's a firebrand man it's it's
remarkable what she's really good
yeah doing that right so so now you you
have a show that just dropped
like days ago from the from yes moment
of this recording
and i already know people who have
binged the entire series and i said yeah
damn so i so i confess
i just read some of the reviews i
haven't seen
any of them yet but i just like the fact
that you're a virologist
but in utopia it is curiously
weirdly sin
uh
so what's up with that um
it's pretty crazy man i mean this is
based on a british show
utopia was on the bbc a long time ago
like 10 years ago
as was the office uh
thank you yes and in fact we're fighting
that same battle there are these
hardcore fanboys of the british original
series like
the american series sucks it's gonna
fail it's terrible
and um always makes more money in
america than in england so
but i don't i don't get that argument
because no one's taking away that tv
show like no one
when we made the american office we
didn't take all copies of the british
office and like burn them
like watch them like you can watch them
over
and over and over plus it's an american
office show in an american office
right it's not america's been a british
location right yes
exactly but utopia is the same thing so
and it's been
being developed for years gillian flynn
was a showrunner and creator of our
version
and um it's all about conspiracy
theories which
parallels are creepy so so give me a
give me a like
you know three sentence overview of what
you're doing
and comic book geeks discover a graphic
novel that contains the keys to the
destruction of humanity
which includes uh crazy viruses
and a super villain named mr rabbit
okay that's how it reaches how's that
then it takes off from there and then
and it's all it's all downhill
yeah it's so it's conspiracy theory
thriller with some science fiction
and uh and drama and really dark
uh sense of humor i call it stranger
things meets quentin tarantino
oh oh so it's got some blood blood it
has it has
yeah human heads okay so tell me tell me
about the virus what's the virus up to
in this storytelling yes so in this
story there my i play a virologist dr
michael stearns who
discovered a really obscure virus in the
andes mountains in peru
that killed a couple hundred members of
the peruvian military
and so i studied it and i created up a
super vaccine that not only
inoculates it but cures let me guess
uh you're a scientist you call this to
people's attention and no one listens to
you
no one listens no one cares
i'm just spitballing there yeah
exactly so right then i'm so i'm just
relegated to kind of researching this
virus in the basement of my college in
chicago i'm a
small potatoes guy and then there
happens to be this huge pandemic
sweeping america
and the parallels between my virus and
this one are very
stunning and so it does turn out that
my virus is the virus that is killing
hundreds or thousands in america so all
of a sudden i get thrust into the
spotlight
and i become this very very unlikely
hero
oh okay well it's good to have a
scientist as a hero
even if it's in a uh a gory weird
storytelling yeah no it is it is usually
the scientist gets long
forgotten after you pass them by in the
beginning of this of a
storytelling so i'm happy to to learn of
this yeah yeah and
and and the is there does it also
address
social cultural things like fear
vaccines and this sort of thing
yes yes it does and it was amazing so we
shot this thing
we finished this thing in september the
virus
the wujan virus started in december the
pandemic was in
february or march and um
we were texting each other like january
february march like what is
happening here is our show coming true
this is
nuts because not only is it the virus
but there's a whole segment of the show
that's about the vaccines the production
of vaccines
rushing the vaccine to market how are we
going to get this vaccine out
um what it means is you have a
really effective pr firm
apparently apparently yeah
that's i guess that's it yeah so they
started the
lujan virus yes you're a pr i think i
i'm
waiting for because this is an amazon
show i'm waiting for the conspiracy
theory that jeff bezos
started the virus in order to promote
utopia
on amazon prime right and with everyone
with the virus
no one is going out so everyone needs
their stuff shipped so that's the
amazing exactly
exactly yeah he's the only one you know
he'll be a trillionaire by the time this
is over so rain we got it we got to
take a quick break but when we come back
uh more with
lorraine wilson one of our patron
geek saints out there and we're going to
take questions from our own fan base
specifically
our patreon patrons when star talk
returns
we're back star talk a cosmic crib
edition we're in conversation with
rayne wilson who's that actor and i
just learned a climate activist and
guy can i call you that rain the climate
why not yeah i'll take it
you'll take it okay yeah um and so right
now in this
portion we we're gonna solicit we've
solicited questions from our fan base
and we're gonna lead off with uh patreon
members these are the folks who
who actively support our podcast so
uh we got a question right here for you
rain
all right so when reading and memorizing
scripts for a science-heavy show
like utopia how much of what you need
and learn sticks with you and furthers
your understanding
of science in general also just
wondering what was your favorite
comic book character ah nice okay
good but you answered that first because
that's presumably a fast fast question
favorite comic book character so here's
the deal with me in comic books
so i was a huge comic book nerd as
a child and then around 11 or 12
i discovered these things neil called
books
they don't have pictures in them there's
no pictures
there's just stories no i'm just i'm
just i'm just giving i'm giving him [ __ ]
i uh i switched over to science fiction
but i have in
the other room of our house i have my
1970s and 1980s science fiction book
collections like 400
books that i read when i was a teenager
so dungeons and dragons
and science fiction books were how i
lived my teenage years
uh but famous ultimately
favorite comic book character um i loved
superman at first and then green lantern
because i figured out that green lantern
could kick superman's butt
uh by just making a kryptonite shell
around him
but then i always was i really loved
thor i i because i loved mythology and i
loved the way that it blended
kind of norse myths and mythological
characters with superheroes so i i was
really big into
excellent so if you're first into
superman and later into thor those are
the two
authentic alien superheroes they come
from other planets
that's just that in context in case
that's true i hadn't really even
thought about that i guess because i've
always felt like an alien myself kind of
so there you have it okay so now tell me
i'm i'm i i actually claim
cameo appearances in five
feature length films but that doesn't
make me an actor
and if i'm playing myself i don't really
have to prepare for it
so as an actor what is the relationship
between
preparing for a role where that role has
expertise
and and what might be real expertise
that you'd glean along the way
that's this question that was just asked
yeah this is a great it's a great
question and i get asked this one a lot
um
i unfortunately you know i spent years
playing a paper salesman and i didn't
have to do
a lot of research did you train for that
yeah
and a beet farmer i didn't like research
like
beet growing harvest yields and and
irrigation techniques for the sugar beet
but um for but imagine how much better
you would have been
had you i know i'm kicking myself right
now
but i'm i will be i'll be brutally
honest so i play a virologist
and i didn't do any research on what a
virologist does
or learns or anything like that i'm
sorry i apologize
science nerds um but
because in this case and i would if i
was
in if it if it really was about the
science like if this was a show where
i was in the lab a lot and doing work
and talking about concepts of viruses
and stuff
but i start in the lab and i'm
immediately like
episode 2 just like launched out into
the world and
i don't really deal with the science of
it so much so i knew it wouldn't really
help my performance or my kind of
authenticity to kind of
dive into the research is that because
it's scripted in a way where
you are more than just a scientist
you're a whole person
who's interacting with a social ecology
that's out there
because for example i forgot which show
it was it was one of these doctor shows
and there's lawrence fishburne
as the uh the medical examiner
performing autopsies right
so they don't put him out in the field
too much
you know when you go down into the
bowels of the
of the where they store the bodies he's
there and so
his lines have to come out convincingly
to what might be an audience
who has fluency in the analysis of dead
bodies
so presumably some of your lines have to
be sort of medically authentic
when you deliver them well in this case
and in this case there was really only a
handful like
i'm talking three or four lines over the
entire series that needed to kind of
sound
uh medically and scientifically
authentic
when you're doing a tv show and you're
in the milieu and you're playing a
doctor or surgeon or a specialist or
something like that
you're coming back time and time again
you know like dr house or something like
that
yeah you really might need to learn some
more about medicine
to be able to every single episode be
diving into some
right and be offended and authentically
deliver the lines right i mean that's
it's gotta it's gotta at least sound
convincing to some experts and
especially
in the geekaverse you'll be held to that
you know
people who are experts or no experts or
and you know i'm a big well i i i'm
known
yeah you do this in the movies all the
time yeah i remember i watched your live
i literally followed your live twitter
feed of um
was it gravity i think it was gravity um
like everything that was right and most
things that were wrong
it was uh it was yeah it was really
interesting it was mysteries of gravity
that's what that was
that was the hashtag i created for it um
but i try to give some latitude
to the creative arts so people think i'm
just
a total you know nasty person to ever
see a movie with
but i did i think i'm just misunderstood
you know
oh yeah thank you you need a hug
okay yeah so um let's get another
question from
uh one of our patreon members and
oh sorry i didn't give the name of that
for that first person uh was uh robert
stanley
yes okay so uh and the next one is
uh chris hampton and uh these are
clearly your fans hey rayne
that's where i have another house chris
hampton chris hampton
that's east of west hampton right or
right uh
it's like hey rayne so these are like
total fan fan folks out there huge fan
uh do you ever get into deep
conversations
about the universe with the other actors
on set
if so who have you had the best
conversations with
oh that's fantastic so let's broaden
that to just your
you know not only utopia but also the
office so how about that
yeah that's great um in the downtime in
downtime yeah
yeah yeah sure we do we you know there's
a lot of downtime when you're on the set
so there's a lot of like really deep uh
conversations
i the one that just popped into my mind
uh
immediately was i did a long time ago
now it's got 15 years ago i did a role
in this
action uh adventure comedy with matthew
mcconaughey called sahara
and i miss that okay yeah it's it's a
big silly
romp through morocco and explosions and
camels and hidden treasures
and cats so
there's a little bit more to it than
that but um and i played a science
geeky nerd in that one but uh i remember
uh talking to penelope cruz and i was
just
blown away by how smart she was
and how i mean first of all she's like
the most beautiful woman on planet earth
so it was a little bit my jaw was kind
of dropped
but she's you know she speaks five
languages she runs all these orphanages
she has got university degrees she's
very well read she's
you can only know that in the downtime
now that i think about it that's how
exactly
that yeah just sipping on a coffee
eating on a sandwich and um
we just had some uh we didn't have a
bunch but i just remember this one
conversation we were talking about
you know world peace and how to achieve
it and working together
and different cultures coming together
and some big concepts and i was just
su super impressed with her i i did not
know that about penelope cruz but yeah
very
very very good to hear genius supermodel
genius basically
i have a very opposite experience that i
once had
okay um i was filming again in a cameo
role
and we're between takes so i'm sitting
in my you know
in the in the in the chair you know with
the director's chair but of course i'm
not the director i'm just
but that's what they're called the
director's chairs and there's someone
else
one of the other actors is there and so
there's some new photo from the hubble
telescope that had just arrived
and i just i'm excited i'm an
astrophysicist i say oh have you seen
this photo
the stars being born in the middle of
this gas guy and
oh okay and then went back to reading
people magazine oh and this is a person
who was playing a medical doctor
and i was just so you know and again i
i'm
i'm naive to assume that an actor is the
thing that they're acting
the fact that they're so good at what
they're portraying making me think that
they know their stuff
that's why they're a good actor okay so
i i it's i'm so torn by this reality
that um right an actor can be completely
ignorant about everything in the world
and all that matters is they deliver
those lines
and so yeah at the end of the day actors
are idiots
you said it you said it back and first
actually idiots just they're neil
degrasse tyson well
i'll say something else here okay just
to just to dig myself out of the hole
that you just said even though i dug the
hole
okay so um i remembered
the in a scene she was in where she
delivered a line and the director said
no you need the line to be this is a
person you remember from the past
and you had good memories then but then
you had later bad memories
so you have conflicted emotions go and
out came
three lines it was like yes it's all
there
in the body and the eyes and the and the
gestures
and and i said damn tan that's good
and so i asked her in in the in the
break
i said well so how long have you been
acting he said well yeah it depends on
when you want to start counting but
um since i was six i was like okay wow
yeah so so if so if you ask me how long
you've been thinking about the universe
it's like
since i was nine right i can i got that
and i'm i'm totally
i'm all in in the universe yeah so yeah
so and she was all in with the acting
i appreciate that there's a people don't
it
a great actor makes it look so easy and
effortless i always use brad pitt as the
example like
it's just like everyone watches a brad
pitt performance you're like i could do
that if i was that good looking i could
do that i mean he just is standing there
oh that's the that's the only thing so
yeah if i had that won the genetic
lottery like he had i could do it
but brad pitt is a phenomenal actor i
mean
transformative subtle precise emotional
like he i'm astounded at his the
intelligence of his performances
i loved him in once upon a time in la
and and he wasn't even the star of that
yeah he was in it but he was like a
secondary kind of character
he's mesmerizing so it's really
complicated and you you know you spend
your whole life
making it look really easy um but
you hope someone notices and then you
get the next gig yeah let's do one more
question before we
take the take the next break so this one
is from
uh this is violetta a 12 year old
astro nerd in birmingham
alabama and my mom izzy
is also a nerd
[Laughter]
nerd nerd nerd soup here okay we want to
know
uh do you consider yourself a nerd
and if so what level of nerd are you
and what's the nerdiest thing you've
ever done
thanks love you guys okay we only have a
couple minutes so
we need a fast answer here okay i love
this question
i have a chest clock over my right
shoulder
that should prove it to you i used to be
i used to play competitive chess and i
was on the chess team
and we would drive around competing in
chess and once i went to a chess
tournament
and i saw a guy who had mold growing in
his ear
i'm not exaggerating that's how nerdy i
am
okay okay you didn't have the mold but
someone next to you did
you're hanging out with that crowd i was
hanging out with the crowd with a guy
who had mold in his ear
that's okay how nerdy i am boom i'm
gonna answer this too so i'm nerd from
way back i went to the bronx high school
of science
but i was kind of a nerd jock so you
know the whole the whole spectrum
of tribalizing that goes on in high
school we have the jocks and the nerds
um in the bronx high school of science
everybody's a nerd so
so this the nerd spectrum has shifted
the whole high school spectrum is
shifted in the nerd direction
so everybody is a nerd i was just a nerd
jock
and then you had the nerd the nerd nerds
okay they were like
extra so so for me
uh what's the nerdiest thing i did i
once wrote down
every single number
that had any significance that i knew at
that moment
so so it was a whole sheet so it was
like all the digits of pi
that i knew i also happen to know the
fifth root of 100 to 12 decimal places
but that's another
story um every phone number that i knew
including their area codes so these are
10 digit numbers uh other
other numbers i just wrote that and i
said how many numbers
could possibly be in my head that are
just there for random access
yeah i filled an entire sheet and each
number has
had meaning in my life i thought that
was kind of a geeky thing to do
that that takes the cake that's that's
that's
that's remarkable i just thought maybe
that was kind of geeky although i do
have notebooks
uh filled with my uh god i wish i could
just
grab one right now i've got notebooks
filled with the drawings i did of my
dungeons and dragons characters
okay all right yeah that's good
okay izzy mom izzy and violetta
where we are on that scale um and just
briefly
however nerdy you think you are there
are people who are way more nerdy than
you are
true and when i finally calculated the
mass of thor's hammer
um someone corrected my calculation to
say
the actual mass of thor's hour
oh my my calculation was as geeky a
thing as
i've ever done with the superhero
universe and that is the marvel universe
of course
and then someone out geeked me who was a
a a
a a material science engineer who worked
for the navy
who had all kinds of superhero
paraphernalia in his office
and he he showed me the errors of my
calculation
oh man and was he right yeah i had to i
had to concede
wow good well good for you that you had
the humility to say you know what
you got me on that you got it yeah so so
it turns out
um i calculated that his hammer weighed
the equivalent of a herd of 300 billion
elephants
and i had authentic ways to calculate
that he said no
it's actually made of a fictional
substance called
and it weighs exactly 42.3 pounds
and my answer was so much better than
that
so but i had to concede i conceived and
then one of my fans said no neil neil
um they didn't say on what planet it
weighs 42.3 pounds
because you weigh different amounts on
different planets sure but sure anyhow
uh we got to take a break and we when we
come back rain if you have questions for
me
that'll be the chance to ask great when
star talk returns
we're back star talk cosmic crib welcome
to it
and in my cosmic crib i got rain wilson
rain
i've been a delight in conversation with
you the first time we've met
and uh and i'm also i i feel good that
we've
exposed your geek underbelly it's
actually not your underbelly it's all
around you
it's my literal belly it's your little
belly not your underbelly it's on top
uh all around you um and you said you
you were avid chess player did you have
a
ranking or score what are they called i
think um in
tournament play i got up to around
1350 1400 so it's not like i was like a
chess genius or anything like that
movies about your chess
prowess but no one was gonna be making
movies about my chess prowess but i
i was fourth board i was fourth board at
shore crest high school in uh
in 1982. uh okay uh
and and i held my own so i did i did
pretty good
all right all right well congratulations
on that and so
uh in this third segment uh we want to i
just want to probe what are the depths
of your cosmic curiosity
because it's not every day someone hangs
out with an astrophysicist and i want
people to
fully exploit that occasion if they want
to so
yeah so listen i hear a lot from people
um about this thing that einstein
referenced
spooky action at a distance and then i
know that this is kind of a
controversial
concept and i just can't wrap my head
around it i'm
i'm really uh a science neophyte around
this stuff and i
really have a hard time taking science
and math into my brain but
um you know i know it has to do with
theoretical physics
and kind of some some
uh experiment or some happening in one
place affecting something in some other
place
and i'm just wondering what that means
what that i always hear that and i just
don't i try to watch a youtube video on
it
i love the way you said that all right
it predates einstein let's go back to
isaac newton
so when isaac newton first wrote down
his equations of gravity
and in these equations there's a mass
term of one object and a mass term and
another you multiply them together
and you divide by the distance between
them
squared and when you do that that's the
force of gravity between these two
objects
so these two objects add a distance from
each other
feel each other's presence but he knew
there's nothing in space there's no
cable connecting them
there are no there's no pulleys
it's empty and this deeply disturbed
isaac newton it's like there's got to be
some way that they're physically
connecting to each other
but until we discover that way i know my
equations work
so i'm sticking with my equations okay
so the equations work
the orbit of the moon around the earth
earth around the sun
jupiter's moons around jupiter that you
could see with a telescope
it was knocking him out of the park but
he was
uncomfortable that you could have action
at a distance and thus became this quest
for is there something else going on in
space
that enables these two objects to know
about each other
and then we ended up exploring
electromagnetism there's another thing
action at a distance okay magnet there's
a magnetic field the concept of field
had to be introduced right and that was
faraday in the
19th century faraday introduced the
console as a magnetic field
and if we're talking about fields we
have a gravitational field if you want
to talk that way
and it's the zone out there where things
can happen
but there's still the mystery of what's
going on
across what is gapping that distance and
it took modern feel theory to come to an
understanding of it
so before i get to that let's get the
gravity solved so einstein
figured out that gravity is not action
at a distance gravity is a distortion of
the
fabric of space and time and i
as a mass am distorting space around me
and if you want to move
in my space you're going to follow that
path
so einstein is quoted as saying that
mass tells space how to curve
space tells matter how to move
so it kind of sidestep the action at a
distance question
because you're just sliding up and down
like like a skateboarder on a on a
on a varied terrain going up and down in
the hole and out of the hole
that that's what things are doing when
things are in orbit they're just sort of
falling on this curved fabric of space
time
so that kind of buys us some time on
this
all right maybe that's all we have to do
to think about gravity
with electromagnetism we're not talking
about spooky action at a distance it's
a photon is exchanged between two
particles
and that creates the force so photons
carry
the force of electricity and magnetism
that's modern
field theory describing that and so
we're done there so now
you folded that together with this other
thing which is
wait a minute there's something way over
here and something's happening and it's
not gravity and it's not
electromagnetism
there's something else that i think was
part of your question
is the quantum entanglement
and so quantum entanglement is is where
you can have two particles
you know you heard that particles can be
wave you know matter can be wave and
particles at the same time you might
have heard about that the wave particle
duality
well okay if you create a particle
you can create a pair of particles that
are entangled with each other
where they have complementary properties
all right now separate the particles
you don't know what properties one of
them has
until you measure it you just don't know
but the moment you measure it you
instantly know the properties of the
other particle because they're
complementary
okay what one is the other is sort of
the complementary variant on that
so if you separate these particles
and don't measure them just separate
them put them at great distance
then the instant you measure this
particle the other particle
shows up with the complementary
properties
and so the wave is occupying that entire
space
and they instantly know about each other
that is the
crowning achievement of action at a
distance
in fact this information communicates
this
happens faster than the speed of light
it happens instantaneously
so sci-fi people are asking is there can
you make a warp drive that'll do this
instantaneously and send something
information
instantly so there's a whole frontier of
sci-fi people thinking about this
phenomenon
well that's what i was going to say nick
that's the first thing that popped into
my head is like
wait so these two
i don't want to say elements but these
two particles
particles that have been split apart are
can
connect with each other commun cannot
communicate like language but
there there's a tension between them you
know is
is is is faster than light space travel
a possibility you know other than this
quantum entanglement phenomenon
um and a few other quant there's quantum
tunneling uh which is also an
instantaneous thing but other than that
moving physical objects through space
faster than the speed of light
there's no known exception to it and
highly tested
laws of physics that say it's impossible
so we're kind of stuck with that
yo what you need you need warp drives
you have to bend space
and then you cheat by cutting across
shortcuts through it
or tunneling through wormholes you can
do it
you're not going to accomplish it by
physically moving faster than like
through
space so so there you have it
that's good now i'm thinking of you in
in galaxy quest uh you can't shake that
that was my first role in the movie that
was if you're supporting alien
another question i had for you is like
what is what was your most
transcendent experience in astrophysics
or astronomy that was filled with the
most
wonder like what discovery or
galaxy or uh
experiment did you kind of witness
that kind of made you gasp and
uh really stretched the limits of your
of your wonder yeah i like that and i
think
wonder is an undervalued
feature of what it is to be a scientist
or to be anyone on a frontier
we have one foot in what is known and
the other foot in what is yet to be
discovered
many people fear that they have to have
an answer they can't
bask in the ignorance of the yet to be
known
and that's unfortunate because the
wonder is the
to gaze upon something and say i have no
idea what i'm looking at
and and let me find out rather than i
have no idea i'm looking at i'm afraid
let me run back into the cave
right these are two wholly different
reactions
so for me uh for parts of my phd thesis
it involved obtaining data at on
mountaintops and
i went to mountaintops in the country of
chile
where those telescopes have access to
the southern hemisphere skies
where the center of the galaxy passes
overhead
in the middle of their winter which is
the middle of our summer
so i would be there on the mountaintop
and this was a pilgrimage because i have
to travel all these
thousands of miles into the southern
hemisphere then
you have to flip your biorhythms to go
nocturnal because your night becomes
your day
all right and so so then there's this
sort of physiological transformation
then you have to
regain your intellectual chops because
you're about to get data that's going to
plug into research
that you already have in progress okay
so then
the sun sets
there's a cloud layer that happens to
roll in
well that cloud layer is below you
because you're on a mountaintop
yeah okay so now the collar completely
surrounds you
and the moon is out just a little bit so
as it gets dark there's still a little
bit of light
i can see the tops of the clouds in
moonlight
and i'm this island of rock
with telescope domes that is ascended
above this cloud layer
and there's nothing else in the world
nothing in your sight line to the
horizon except
you on this mountaintop above the clouds
so it's me on earth but really above
earth looking out to the universe ready
to point my telescope to the center of
the galaxy
waiting for photons that have been
traveling for 30 000
years emanating from the middle of the
galaxy
to land on my detector
and so and i'm there alone this is a
very solid well there's a
technician in another room but
it it it is a a moment when you are
communing
with the cosmos and
uh for me that is the closest
thing i've had to a religious
spiritual moment not religious in the
sense of oh there are gods up there no
no just a spiritual moment where
i'm not in this moment i'm not thinking
of the universe
i'm feeling it
and that's happened to me many times on
the mountaintop
wow that's that's a great story that's
fantastic yeah
i feel like those moments of
transcendence
is what we're really going for you know
as as as human beings on this planet
like that and
some people have never had it might not
know that that is something to go for
yes so that's true that's true that's a
it's a direction ahead but
i've had that same experience at a
radiohead concert
oh okay i did not expect
that's you to say that i've had that
same experience
uh you know camping and being in the
wilderness and seeing the stars
um i've had that same experience the
birth of my son
um but those moments okay wait does your
son know that
you've analogized his birth to a
radiohead concert just
he would be through close this he's a
huge radiohead fan he's 16. he's already
seen them in concert twice
he would be thrilled all right well dude
that's a i'd love that question and
thanks for
for for uh empowering me to relive that
moment which was very special for me
and dude we got to get you back on at
another time i don't think we've plumbed
all
of the nerd space that we're capable of
reaching
happy birthday wilson thank you for
being on star talk
dr neil degrasse tyson you're very
welcome
all right this has been star talk let's
call it the rain wilson edition
uh i've been your host neil degrasse
tyson your personal actual physicist
as always getting you keep looking up